an ecotone is like a Frontier where
elements usually separated thrive in
friction interact communicate
[Music]
if you're anything like me this sound
should make you very uncomfortable
unpleasant but this is what 55% of the
population hears daily
worldwide however our ancient acoustic
environment was was different today I
invite you to listen with me to this
Orchestra again how the Thunder the wind
birds singing Thrills buses Roar join
and become the Instinct in an untamed
landscape and I invite you to listen how
we humans have merged our own sound into
this
Symphony
on this island I will show you a
fragment of our own Evolution this is
Loma a place that has harbored for more
than 15 centuries a whistle
Communication
System but that's not all this island
has a secret just in its Center for
thousands of years this island has
protected the oldest music the natural
soundscape a sound that only reaches its
maximum complexity in the most intact
ecosystems the oldest ones almost
ancestral Miss have preserved a living
fossil called lri Silva a forest that
otherwise would not be here at this
latitude the same as the Saharan
Desert here animals have created a
unique chorus now pay attention listen
with
me this sound is the result of millions
of years of evolution it it is probable
that our ancestors could understand this
sound better than us with their
curiosity they would even imitate it the
cous rhythms it
stones but today we don't have the time
for that
anymore so we have program recorders to
get the sound of the island and its
rules every hour of each day during the
Four Seasons to be able to understand it
this is the
spring
[Music]
let's play a little just as we could
have done in the past here and now we
are going to imitate using the
recordings and their Dynamics we are
going to create music for starters each
species has its own
tones its
register its
songs and its favorite tone for example
black Spur's favorite tone is at 1.95
khz B major
[Music]
and as the ecosystem gets older
different species tend to occupy more
and more
notes from the lowest to the highest
[Music]
pitches
avoiding song overlap so they can make
themselves better heard creator ryons
[Music]
cses
as the climate changes and moves towards
the summer soundscape becomes simpler
[Music]
subtler and in the meantime I wonder
what if in the past is listening the
imitation could contribute to shape our
own
communication
spe
[Music]
fore
the reason why this imitation occurs so
easily even spontaneously it's because
both the Blackbirds and the human
inhabitants have adapted their
communication specifically to the island
the dominant frequency coincides around
the 1.95 khz Silo being slightly lower
than the dominant sound of wildlife
perhaps a casual convergence to the
environment or perhaps not it's hard to
know partly because the use of Silo has
changed
Silo became distant from the landscape
but Landscapes have also changed in 2012
a wildfire burned the forest south of
the island and with them the soundscape
created during generations of
generations of animals was
lost
but silence is slowly filled little by
little with new
sounds
for
foreign
fore
night makes me imagine other times and I
keep wondering why does Silo sound the
way it
does Midnight has its own
rules this Cricut chus for example
lowers its Stone as the heat leaves the
ground and I wonder if Sila could also
adapt to different situations perhaps to
distances or or
humidity how it could have been before
the
60s when there were no
phones no
internet
foree
spee
for
speee
spe
spee
for
when the Autumn ends animals in the
island restart their maximum singing
activity even in the burnt
area
young bation gives shelter to a newcomer
biological
community slowly feeling the
silences creating new
soundscapes
and with enough protection this Forest
will grow and we'll hear new
orchestras
[Music]
in winter birds get ready for breathing
season their acoustic activity is very
high once
again
too much heat would alter their behavior
towards slower rhythms and less occupied
tones instead the mild temperatures of
winter are
[Music]
optimal
w
for
[Music]
speech
spee
fore
it is not known if Silo originated in
Lera or if it could come from the
mountains north of Africa the fact is
there are whistlers there too very few
who whistle in their own language with
their own social dynamics and perhaps
natural ones in fact their whistling has
a higher pitch than Silo and would not
overlap with the soundscapes we've been
listening to
here perhaps am giving you more
questions than answers but that is how
knowledge works for now I leave you
wondering reflecting about what can we
learn from soundscapes and about
ourselves once someone invented the word
nature from Latin NATA deriving from the
verb nasty which means being born when
we talk about nature as if it's
something apart from us we despise our
birth Earth we separate from our origin
and identity and isolate as a species
from the rest of
ecosystems listening to our surroundings
recognizing a fragment of our evolution
perhaps can bring us closer to our
Origins to hear our own voice in a
planet full of other species singing of
the Thunder of the Roar of the Sea of a
wind that take us through the air to
understand that we are not an isolated
entity while Silo Finds Its place in the
future we should also rethink ours today
I encouraged you to go outside pause
stop and
listen
[Music]
for